find the area of the trapezoid so the
area of a trapezoid I'll say that a and
I'll put a little small T here so that
we're finding the area of the trapezoid
the easiest way to think about it is it
is the average of the bases times the
height so the average of the basis is 15
plus 11 divided by 2 sometimes you'll
see in formulas this is base 1 this is
base 2 this is base 1 base 2 a trapezoid
I've assessed to parallel bases so it's
the average of the bases 15 plus 11 over
2 times the height and the height here
is 4 centimeters times 4 and this units
these are the units here are in
centimeters the units here and
centimeters so when you multiply it
you're going to get centimeters squared
but let's actually evaluate it so 15
plus 11 is 36 so this is going to be 36
or sorry it's 26 15 plus 11 is 26
divided by 2 is 13 and then you have 13
times 4 times 4 which is equal to 40
plus 12 it's 52 and then square
centimeters and we're done we found the
area of the trapezoid and if you're
wondering why does this why does this
thing here make sense and one way to
think about it is imagine imagine you
were to take the area of just of just
using this base so if you were to look
at the rectangle that has this base and
that height and you would have this area
that I'm showing you in white if I just
took 11 times 4 you would get this area
right over there so 11 times 4 would be
this area right over here and if I took
15 times 4 I would get this entire
rectangle I would get this entire
rectangle so 15 times 4 would be the
entire rectangle so even include some of
this area that is not included in the
trapezoid and if you look at light if
you look at this and it's not a rigorous
proof but it's giving you the intuition
why this is the formula the actual area
of the trapezoid is exactly in between
these two areas it's in between this
white area
and thus larger the area of the larger
rectangle and you could see that because
there's these lines divided the kind of
the difference between the two areas
it divides them in two so the area of
the trapezoid is actually if you average
these two numbers so if you if you add
them together and you divide by two
which is the same thing as four times
the average of the bases 11 plus 15 over
2 either way this is the answer 52
centimeters squared